bonjour
j'ai hâte qu'elle soit là maintenant elle
semble bien où dit-elle qu'elle avait
un petit ami ils étaient dans les
Catskills tu ressembles à une baie martienne
tu l'aimes ici ouais tu as un
très bel endroit ici c'est autant à
toi que  c'est à moi
eh bien elle c'est juste une image que tu
dois partager ouais ne sois pas égoïste
ouais
alors je suis mon mur
où vont-ils il est juste grand la mort
est belle la
mort est pure tu es un enseignant et un
leader marcinho  prouvez-le
tirez-le ce sont des animaux vivants alors tirez
max alors ce que je sais qui je suis je suis un
enseignant et le leader tu ne
me laisses jamais être que nous ne pouvons pas ignorer le fait que
son comportement est
[Musique]
ce qui t'est arrivé